When Mobile browers first came along the content on
the Web wasn't designed for narrow small screen devices. It
was designed for Windows that were around 1,000 pixels wide
and wider than they were tall with easy scrolling. To
Shoehorn this content into a tiny Mobile screen since
rendering a Web Page designed for 1,000 pixels across and
a 320 pixel wide screen would mean you'd be scrolling
a lot. Mobile browsers basically lied about the Window width.
They made the Window act as if it were
980 pixels wide, even though the original iPhone was only
320 pixels across. This enabled sites that were designed for
a 1024 by 768 screen, that is, that were around
980 pixels wide to fit on the Mobile screen. Although
you needed to a do a lot of Zooming to
read the text sometimes. Unfortunately if your site did not
happen to match that 980 pixel width you were either
going to overflow or underflow the screen. Either wasting
space or forcing the User to Zoom. In order
to control this, Apple provided a viewport meta tag
to be added to your HTML to control the
default For how big should my screen act on
this page? The default is 980. So, if you
put 980 here, it would have no effect. The
Mobile browser already defaults to 980. But setting a viewport
tells the browser how wide the content is
intended to be, and then the browser scales
to make that size fit on the device's
screen. There are two ways to use this tag.